hello and welcome back to Juniors we're
going to watch a tape and this is going
to tell us a little more about this
universe that we should have known
already or maybe we shouldn't have I
don't know maybe we don't want to know
oh it's adorable
oh it's traumatized
oh it has anxiety
oh it's Bonnie okay
no it's
oh it's going into a downward spiral oh
just like the Freddy Fazbear we all know
and love so
um uh Paul Bearer what do you have to oh
I'm sorry
[Music]
I'm sorry
[Music]
oh now it's Bonnie's turn Okay so that
was some way of like suggesting that it
was going to be
on his turn I get it and now Bonnie's
dead is Bonnie dead
who knows Only We Know I guess or we're
going to know is that getting bloodier
I don't know
a new
a new friend I don't know if I want a
new friend what happened to Freddy what
happened to Bonnie
what happened to any of them
that's a lie I do like this
hello uh it's me again anything new in
here
yeah that's still weird any new rules
no okay all right oh
hello
oh
did I climb the tree I think I climbed
the tree I'm not Harbison sure about
that
we're running out of time my
investigation ends soon
how troubling
we need to Signal the ghost in juniors
and invade the thing she's protecting
the most
I don't like the phrasing the mangle
exactly by now she knows I'm with you
I'm what she wants
are you that's a you get a lot of
presumptions here so be it she'll have
to go through me first I don't know why
I'm so protective of you figment of my
imagination in my dreams
after the next night we will take the
ghost by surprise we'll sneak into the
basement and figure it out from there
I'm glad to have a friend like you
I don't remember the last time I had
someone to talk to
for as long as I can remember it's just
been myself and the spirits and this
giant brain floating above us ominously
I can hear its thoughts it's it's a nice
change of pace you know to have a friend
like you around
said it whatever is waiting for us in
the basement the mangle
it's nothing we can't handle together
you and me thick and thin through and
through sickness and health
fast friends except that I don't really
know who you are anyway get in here
so bye mangle do you mean that I'm gonna
have to worry about that
um as we play as I play everyone The
Gangs all here
ever literally the gang's all here
okay so there was nothing weird about
that oh well I guess now there is
oh that's strange
okay so connection lost in the kitchen
but I didn't hear anything in the
kitchen
so
oh connection lost in the dining hall
okay so whatever's doing that is causing
the connection to be lost but how am I
supposed to know
okay so it's not Freddy
because Freddie's still in this Freddy's
still in there clearly
so I can call Freddy in
and Freddie was not the cause of it
neither is Bonnie neither is foxy
so it could be
chica
might be chica I have not seen chica on
the menu and considering that I know
or I kind of know that it's chica that
means I can take advantage of that
by sending others in for repairs right
God I hope it's chica either way it's
not the ones that I've seen for sure two
connections lost
not Bonnie
I think it's chica because it's not
where the music is either
Music's Over There
hello
yeah I think it's chica so I'm gonna and
I don't think it's Bonnie I'm literally
gonna use this as an excuse to get
everyone repaired It's gotta be chica I
don't know where the other one is that
balloon boy or whatever you maybe I
don't know hope it's not you that'd be
weird I just noticed that this was
very cute
in a horrifying way
oh there we go love the love the alarm
that you're there okay I don't think
it's you I think it's chica so I'm gonna
uh yes yes
I'm a genius I'm a goddamn genius yep I
knew it and then the message says the
cameras have been disconnecting for some
reason so there's various different ways
with which
this could be discovered
okay ghost has entered an animatronic
checking this oh well
that makes my job easy
thanks
all right chica get in here well that is
uh good for me
that makes it easy
boy howdy that conveyor is slow I would
like it if that conveyor was not slow
to help what does that mean let me look
what do you mean I've narrowed it down
to Freddie or Bonnie oh did I use my
Lifeline okay well Freddie or Bonnie
that's helpful
so that's good which means that I can uh
call you in if it's Freddy or Bonnie
that's good okay there's foxy not a
concern
no one's ever on the stage
camera shy wait who's that foxy
okay there's Bonnie oh lights are lights
are real jittery
lights are really jittery
I think that yeah I think that it's
Bonnie definitely
oh [ __ ]
go away
okay I think it's Bonnie
great work I'm the best but I used my
lifeline I shouldn't have done that
shouldn't have done that and ghost has
entered an animatronic good
oh well that makes it easy
uh call in so far so good I'm getting
really really good at this
I'm getting quite capable
I'm impressed with myself I think that's
the that must be the only sign that it's
balloon boy right it must be because
what else would cause that that's fine
you might leave a handprint whoa
not you no hand print
okay
oh oh who's doing it some oh is it just
Freddie in there I think it might have
been
I think it might be Freddy oh it might
be Freddy might be Freddy
Freddy or Bonnie could be Freddie or
Bonnie so it's not the others it's
either Freddy or Bonnie
interesting so it's either Freddy or
Bonnie everyone else is doing okay so I
just need to can I get a Lifeline no uh
shoot
okay so Freddie or Bonnie oh well it's
fine Freddy's here so Bonnie oh it's
Bonnie
all right easy
excellent I'm gonna call Bonnie in
because Bonnie needs repairs one more
and we're good
we're going well last night easy
is this the last night I don't think
it's the last night I think this will
only night four I love this though I
love the layout of all this like the way
that this is set up is really elegant
and well well thought out let me just do
a quick check oh well that does make my
job very easy
boom easy peasy who'd-a-thon Paul Bearer
is waiting for me in the basement
deep down in the basement where
nightmares grow and faster and wait to
consume my soul can't wait then the
eagerly looking forward to this oh well
I know you are with him after finishing
your shift you stumble across an old VHS
tape oh what's the harm I bet this is
the one that's the bad one and you
shouldn't watch it but I'm gonna watch
it anyway because I love lore and
nothing will stop me from getting lore
not even death
foreign
[Music]
adorable that is adorable
that's God damn adorable
that's freaking adorable
or bully
[Music]
I really want to know who did these
little animations because they are
fantastic
[Music]
crying blood
I oh no
gotta delivered to the mangle I guess
it's all of our duties we must appease
the mangle oh hey
speak of the mangle okay cool what uh
what do I do about that oh it seems am I
crazy or is it getting a little more you
know
you know is it judging itself up a
little bit more than it has in the past
I feel like it is and I feel like that
means something but I just don't know
what it means
continue
last night of Sanity I haven't had my
sanity since 2015. it's been a long time
since I saw my sanity so nothing really
lost there
nothing left to lose anyway
hello again
Paul Bear
okay everything does seem okay I'm sure
it's fine
the grass popping in and out that's
weird is it doing that before so what's
the plan I don't know you tell me I said
we take the ghost by surprise we just
need a way to get into the basement in
secret I'll cover that I found an
entryway into the basement long ago I
locked it up as soon as I found it I'm
sure the ghost knows it exists so you
must be cautious I'll do my best I'll
finish up my investigation tonight and
we'll meet right back here tomorrow
okay what am I doing this investigation
for and why am I doing it why do I trust
a dream bear I can't even say that if I
was talking to a bear in my sleep that I
would trust it because I don't
all right get in here get in here you oh
God that was quick uh oops hopefully
it's hopefully though they hopefully
that does actually make it immune when I
pull one in like that I really hope it
does because I might be nothing new for
tonight good luck pal thanks thank you
uh
uh
hello
oh no that wasn't that was not what I
thought it was I thought that was the
lights going on and off
something does seem jittery though
oh what was that who's moving people are
moving fast
they're moving real fast okay it is it
is something
is flickering the lights is it Bonnie
might be Bonnie
yeah no it's chica unless there's
someone else chica I'm calling chica
uh calling
I'm great
I'm fantastic give me Wham
wow what was oh my God that's too fast
well this is concerning um that really
fast okay so
you Bonnie
okay so I don't think it's Bonnie so I
could probably get Bonnie in here there
and then I heard
what
what
what
what
was there there's an um is that the
conveyor belt has that always been uh
oh who left a hand print
who left a handprint
oh okay I gotta go take care of that
okay thank you thanks Bon you go and
have good you have good I don't know
what I'm doing
did one of you leave a handprint
okay definitely wasn't Bonnie because
they just got Bonnie in there so if it's
oh everyone's in there no handprint here
it might be musician I'm gonna guess
music music was in that room before
right marionette
I'm boned oh frick please not like this
ah balloon boy no please everyone
oh I'm dead oh no please not like this
no oh freak I'm dead I'm dead oh God no
not like this no please don't kill me
I don't like the hands
I don't like the hands on you I don't
like all the hands how was I so wrong
how was how how was it Freddy
why was it Freddy okay what am I looking
at what did I just see what was that
what it would that thing didn't have a
leg Zoom back in on that
thank you uh what is what is this
analyze analyze scan scan uh give me
details okay thank you okay something is
causing the lights to flimber here
ah that was extremely unhelpful
um not you
okay oh God stay still is it foxy
I think it's foxy but I'm not sure
no wait was it was still going it's
either Freddy or Bonnie okay it's either
Freddy or Bonnie
Freddie or Bonnie who's it
friend of your Bonnie come on
it's Freddy okay got it
all right cool got it yes
all right easy easy easy easy easy easy
easy easy
ghost has entered in animatronic that is
very fast no hand print on lens
it's not chica I don't think anyway
okay someone's here
take care of that hi
goodbye
okay so if it's not
oh why can't I call anybody wait what
why wait hold on I can't
what I can't I
wait
oh did I not get that how did I not get
that okay I'm gonna call you in because
I know that you're you probably only do
the thing when you are
when the screen says that you are
glitching out okay so oh one of them
okay foxy or Bonnie foxy or Bonnie left
a hand print one of them did
so it's either foxy or Bonnie
one of them left a handprint hurry up
thank you
so that means it's not any of you
or foxy or Bonnie
there's still that hand print there it's
one of them there's another handprint
there that doesn't help me there's
leaving handprints all over the place I
think I saw Bonnie like Bonnie the
shadow of Bonnie
not Shadow Bonnie but the shadow of
Bonnie just there I can't find anybody I
think it's Bonnie
but let me just get everyone in Tip-Top
shape just for now
I confirm this
and they're gone okay
wait did I say foxy or Bonnie or Freddie
or Bonnie Freddie you're but oh I'm dead
oh God I'm dead aren't I I didn't mean
oh I'm gonna guess it's funny because if
it's not I'm dead anyway
ah I guessed uh wrong I I misremembered
I thought I had first I don't know I
don't have an excuse for that one
tricky I thought I was getting good at
this turns out no what is up with you
there this doesn't make any sense none
of that makes sense none of none of what
that is makes sense zero of that makes
sense
all right so it wasn't it wasn't
glitching and it wasn't there was no
handprint
a musician is here right now it might be
music
marionette
oh
for very brief moment okay it's either
marionette or Freddy and I'm going to
remember that properly this time
so we I almost did it I almost did the
thing so you get in there it's either
marionette or Freddy I know that
I see the music in here
no camera control
It's gotta be Freddy
Freddy come on glitch my camera
maybe not well it is it is knew it knew
it okay so I know it's you
all right I know it's you
take this thank you
so I know who do I know it it's Freddy
it's definitely I I keep wanting to call
Freddy in
but I won't because I'm smart I am big
brain I am big brain
hi foxy what you up to nah not foxy
no handprint okay oh okay might be music
I heard that
might be music because music was in a
connection lost room might be I'm gonna
call you in
might be music
nope not music not music it is not music
because the music was not there oh nope
music is there never mind might be music
it's not Freddy okay not Freddy
it's not chica not Freddy not foxy I
think that was foxy
yeah not foxy
not Freddie not chica not foxy got it I
think it's music okay hang on
could be Bonnie I haven't seen Bonnie
ooh but it's not Freddy I've seen Freddy
that's for sure
oh music just ended it's not it is
Bonnie
that would have been very bad if I
hadn't done that
oh [ __ ] oh no no
it was freaking it freaking blocks
damn it damn it God damn you okay please
tell me it's not Bonnie because Bonnie
is about to die
I thought for sure didn't I I guess I
didn't see Bonnie technically speaking
no Bonnie must have been in the back
there like that
why did that happen
why did that happen I'm not sure why
that happened
I'm I'm not 100 what did I do uh please
inform me how I was an idiot because I
believe it I believe that I overlooked
something very similar because I'm
saying a lot of things and I'm doing the
exact opposite of my intention almost
all the time it's so uh not good all
right so connection loss so any okay
it's not Bonnie Roger
not Bonnie not foxy
not Freddy not Bonnie not cheeky chica
music got it 100 100 100
get in here
done easy peasy easy peasy
okay so Bonnie Chica maybe maybe it can
be the animatronic that comes on the
conveyor belt and I just have been lucky
up until just this last death I would
believe that so maybe I shouldn't be so
willy-nilly about those conveyor belt
summons because this might be my
untimely death oh one of you okay so
Bonnie or chica okay so it's Bonnie or
chica or I guess music was in there as
well but let me deal with all these guys
come on here chica
Bonnie Chica music which means that it
couldn't have been you
I'll only say what it would be what it
would be okay Bonnie again camera one
funky might be Bonnie
oh
no
music's in here
okay there's Bonnie oh Bonnie's gone
oh Freddy and Chica in here that's
interesting okay so it's Freddy or chica
Freddie or chica
good to know
Freddie or chica not Bonnie not music
I Call Music just in case
oh I think it's chica yeah it does seem
like it evidence points towards chica
evidence points strongly towards chica
yep chica no Bonnie's in there too God I
can't confirm this I cannot it's either
I think it's chica
I think 100 is chica
I'm putting money on it yes oh God I
should not do that I keep doing that and
I don't think that that's quite right I
don't think that that guarantees that
that's not going to be the ghost
I think that's what killed me last time
oh I'm doomed aren't I oh no oh no I
feel it I feel it I feel it I'm doomed I
feel I'm doomed I'm doomed I'm doomed
okay crowded in here
and I gotta go take care of a thing
okay I'm not doomed wow can you believe
it can you believe it I'm not doomed huh
okay you're not freaking out I'll call
you over Red Rover
Red Rover okay I am a little stumped no
hand prints so it's not foxy I don't
think anyway
it doesn't seem to be Bonnie
but I'm not detecting any other kind of
disturbance here the lights are not
flickering
Freddy oh Freddy no
oxy no oh oh oh who's doing it okay
chica foxy or music
foxy or music okay foxy or music are
doing that
so that's foxy your music got it okay
Fox here music uh
not chica it was not chica
oh foxy just came in and the camera's
all wonky
well actually music just left and the
camera was fine
I can't tell I literally can't tell
which one it is I have no idea
it's foxy or the Muppet okay come on
oh I oh it seemed like it might have
just for a moment
oh no
okay no effect
here's foxy oh foxy okay it's got to be
foxy it's 100 100
yes I keep doing that that's gonna be my
death that is that's how I'm gonna die
that is 100 how I'm gonna die oh no
I'm so freaking stupid
I'm so stupid oh I'm so dumb I'm so dumb
oh oh never mind music was here
music's here music chica or Bonnie okay
music teacher or Bonnie
okay music or chica got it okay so it's
either music or chica
uh let's get foxy in okay who is it
music or chica
music
yes yes yes yes yes
okay
oh so we're not seeing one
okay so it's not music which is good
because I need to get you in oh
well that's handy it's uh balloony but
that's good because I need to get these
up anyway so I'm gonna I'm gonna hold
off until I can get these up and then
I'm
gonna keep going
ah maybe I shouldn't
okay five of seven oh my there's so many
oh oh okay all right is this chica was
that chica was that an easy chica that
might have been an easy chica
oh my God I'm the best I did it again oh
please don't be your body
I there's got to be like some protection
there's gotta be like some protection on
that right
don't kill me with six of seven don't
kill me with six of seven that would be
okay good foxy was just in here and Foxy
just left and there's a handprint it
could be foxy
could be foxy
very likely to be foxy there's some
strange clamoring going on behind me I'm
going to ignore it and pretend that it's
not that
nothing's gonna kill me and I'm fine
where's foxy
foxy is not making an appearance
foxy there you are return to the scene
of the crime huh
interesting
oh foxy just left and there's a new
handprint it's foxy 100 oh
yeah all right I'm good
I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm
good
Paul Bearer is waiting for me yeah I bet
he is I bet Polly Bear is
I bet Polly boy is do I get another
tape yes falling down after finishing
your shift you stumble across an old VHS
tape almost as if someone left it there
for me to find which wouldn't be
suspicious at all watch it
[Laughter]
oh creepy
foreign
[Music]
I don't know what I just saw was it
mangle might have been mangle
good all right continue night six
it never really was five nights ever
even in the first one we all know this
we knew this going into it we all knew
it
it was known hello
yay
oh that's interesting what's with the
door
the door ready to venture into the
unknown haven't I been doing that
already I guess we're as ready as we'll
ever be yeah this door will lead you
straight to the center of the basement
that's where we'll find our ghost now I
took a peek and scouted out the basement
while you were doing your investigation
did you see anything
well from what I can make out it seems
the ghost has turned the basement into
their own little game all right then we
need a plan I say we go with whatever
game the ghost is trying to play with us
in traffic by surprise how are we gonna
trap the ghost Trapper here with other
corrupt Spirits let them rot as I have
for centuries
all right then this is it
um
let me trap you here to let you rot for
centuries is this a bad idea it's
probably a bad idea isn't it are you the
mangle all right why do I trust you I
shouldn't okay I don't trust you what oh
then this is it
oh
if this works Paul I may never see you
again so I guess this is goodbye Jr's
Ends Tonight
okay
goodbye forever or maybe not
I have a funny feeling I'm about to be
backstabbed but uh
like it always does you know same old
same old always been the same old well
[Music]
oh God new mechanics please no use aw
and D
oh no mannequin hi uh to use the lights
in your office W to flash in the cameras
press space oh man I'm dead I'm dead
okay I'm trying to read
um space to put in your mask on if
anything is too close be sure to keep
the music box wound by holding left
Mouse button on the circular Vision
visual or space in the prize Corner
camera uh look up I know I'm gonna die
I'm just gonna put this on love the
shades but I'm just gonna accept death
and hold on for dear life because I
don't have enough time for any of this
I'm I'm done
what
did I just see what in the fresh hell
was I seeing with my eyes
all right don't forget to wind the music
box
good
okay all right
oh you are joke they made an entire
other game
all right that's apparently the wind-up
I guess
oh great
oh yeah
oh what is I I feel like that's a
problem whatever was just in front of me
is that not a problem
I guess not anymore
I don't know what I'm doing and I oh
well Frick it's very Five Nights at
Freddy's 2
oh frick oh frick
oh frick
oh boy
oh I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I've tried to get to it oh frick I it's
too late I'm dead
oh my God
that's horrifying I don't like the look
of that thing okay well we got a
completely new game mechanic here that I
have to get used to
but I'm good at this and this is what I
was built for so bring it on [ __ ] I'm
ready for you I'm so ready for you what
do we have we don't have anything it's
all blurs why is it all blurs I don't
know
whatever whatever I don't care I'm on it
I'm on it I'm on it
I'm on it I don't know what I'm looking
for excuse me who did that
okay I don't really have any camera down
front so I can't tell what's there oh I
can oh my God
okay well that was awfully forgiving I
don't know why that allowed me to live
okay yeah that's
so it seems like it there was some
leeway
yeah it's
seems like I did have some time
okay something is there oh god oh my god
did you see that thing but it it does
seem to be okay I don't know how long I
need to last and I don't know if I have
a further objective good oh my God sure
I'm gonna die
that is infinitely more forgiving than
five nights at Freddy's 2
Joe oh my God guys stop where I'm not
ready for it
you are such a son of a [ __ ]
I don't know what I'm looking for I
don't know why I'm looking for that's
probably you just stop stop stop stop
I know that I know I know that
I know what to do with you yeah I knew
it
God this music box
oh my God
stunning whoa
hello again
man this is so frantic I can't even see
or appreciate anything else that's
happening in this game you know what I
mean
Mickey Mouse ass Foxy Get out of here oh
frick
oh come on come on oh not no I need to
move in the music box
oh I'm [ __ ] oh well I guess I didn't
have any chance
is there something else I can do to keep
them from doing that because I'm dead
and and that's not okay
oh man is there nothing I can do to get
that oh frick It's gotta be something
with like using the flashlights I'm not
doing them enough this is frantic if you
see balloon baby in the left hand put on
your mask I don't see anything in the
left hand it's so many flashing lights
that I can't tell what's happening
what heard that
I'm hearing something
oh man
where did you I didn't even see you
I can't even I can't even flash those
yep hello oh I hate you
look at that monstrosity I know I know I
need this it's just not letting me have
it
so I just got to keep it there I have to
because otherwise there's really nothing
I can do it's it's also a very minute
small little Target to hit
I wonder if they go away if I preemptive
no they don't
oh freak
it's easy to miss
so far so good whoa
scary
up come on
I know I know I know I know
nope come on
okay they're just popping out they're
just popping out that's what they do
take my opportunities oh my God hello
go away go away go away
all right
thankfully they have the courtesy of
pulling down my camera for me
oh man I wish I had another button for
opening the freaking camera
oh my God
foreign
all right okay
I don't know how long I need to last I'm
assuming 6 a.m and I might not have
enough power because I am kind of
spamming up the flashlight a bit I know
Foxy in Five Nights at Freddy's 2 was
very much just you flash him with your
light and he'll go away eventually
that's all I know though so other than
that I I don't really know but I am
burning a lot of power 225
come on
oh what is that what is that what is
that but where are the mangle you can't
be what do you mean don't make this more
difficult than you know you can't what
do you what do you mean what am I doing
what am I doing what is what is I don't
know what this is well I can't do
anything what oh uh
is this lore are they all getting turned
into the mangle oh no
oh no
Ah that's not good
Ah that's not good
oh that's not good oh what is that what
is that what are you
hmm
okay well this is really really cool and
all
um but I don't know exactly what to do
about it
so if I die it's gonna be a problem
okay 100 yay
yippee
okay the mangle is here watch out for
her owl tail she would look use it to
look into your office from the vents put
the mask on flash the hallway if she's
there find the ghost in the camera and
hold the light and she will break okay
that's a lot to take in
that was that was a lot of information
to take in what am I doing
oh hey uh that's okay so is that is that
uh hold the light on her and she'll
break eventually okay
so you'll break cameras Oh God oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh what a what is
what what is happening what what oh what
I don't know what I I don't understand
oh my God no put it down
ah okay well oh good it's here okay find
the ghost in the camera hold the light
on her or she will break cameras and
eventually your light okay so I need to
find mangle on the camera and hold a
light on them
right that's what I learned there you
you and gone okay good okay that was
good
oh God what was that whoa
I hate you
okay find find find find
you you're back there we go oh did I not
get that oh god oh [ __ ] I didn't get
that did I
well there you are there you are I see
you I see you
yep
nope go away tip got this I've got this
you okay
okay
oh go oh my God I just saw that out of
the corner of my eye like just then oh
[ __ ] oh no am I dead oh what in the
freaking hell is that
oh my God I don't know what that's about
I hate that
hello
this is awful and I hate it
Yep this is terrible
oh I found the ghost I think did I was
that the ghost today oh
I guess that's the ghost I didn't know
what the ghost really was
um
boy it would be great if I could
actually see some uh
okay so there's like a rattlesnake sound
basically when that slides out
okay you
I can't find it I can't find it it's
nowhere
it's nowhere
I can't find it I don't know where it is
oh did I miss it God damn it I don't
know why I don't know what it I I really
have no idea if I'm doing anything right
am I winning
I don't think I'm winning I don't think
I'm winning
I don't think I'm winning
I don't know I think is that broken or
something
God I don't know what I did I don't know
what I did wrong I don't know why I did
it I think probably the the eyeballs the
ticking those are like descending down
all right
yeah all right okay
I think I just gotta get to this sooner
okay shining on you shining shining
shining okay so that's not doing
anything
that's not doing anything
that didn't do anything so I I needed to
read that tip a little better
because it must have there was some kind
of like ghost thing there
there was it was like a ghosty
translucent nonsense
that was there
there it is I saw it that was a ghost
that was the ghost I got it okay I saw
it I did find it
well when did this happen
when did when did it go black and white
and why is that terrible and why should
I hate that forever
I do not see it anywhere here
it's a problem
this is a big problem
not seeing ghost
I'm not seeing it it keeps cutting out I
can't see anything it cuts out usually
before it would only cut out if like the
camera you were on was the problem
oh found the ghost that was it that was
it definitely it
I don't know if that's gonna save me or
not
there I just saw it
okay that was another Victory good
I don't think I saw it there
you see there definitely not there
it is going yep good
right the ghost the ghost that was
infecting the animatronics of course
that's what I'm looking for
of course it is that's what I've been
looking for the whole time
I don't see it
what oh god what is that what was that
what was that what was that oh my God
what was that I don't know I have no
idea I need to find that ghost
oh it's so good for oh that was it
oh
okay just a little more I've only got so
much battery left
oh my God I can't see anything
this is like completely stopped up
come on oh give me something there it is
oh that might be that might be it that
might be it that might be it game over
gg gg
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
that was good
that was good
oh never mind hi go away please I don't
know I'm bad
no you know I'm good
I'm all right you stay out
you stay out thank you very much
no thank you
ah back here again am I good
good great whoa I'm back she must have
gotten in my head uh did she pallbear
where are you
please don't hurt me oh oh no
I knew you were here all along
while you were sitting in here behind
that costume I was waiting
waiting so patiently for another one of
your little puppets to look where they
weren't supposed to once I'm done with
you
I'm gonna take your little puppet and
split his skull not this time he's
different he's built different oh really
let me ask you this what makes you think
he will be able to avenge your spirit
now
this on Ax
all close enough it's done
[Music]
after five years Jr Juniors would reopen
or Jr's
think juniors
it would go over heavy rebranding as
some still have a somewhat negative
impression of the company
okay
don't tell me
Fazbear entertainment is now more
committed than ever to family fun and
above all safety
they've spent a small fortune on these
new animatronics ready and willing to
take it to the next level of fun
so this is all a precursor I love it
anyways Jeremy when do you think you can
start oh Jeremy
oh I love it that was really really well
made and I'm guessing that's why I felt
so much like Five Nights at Freddy's 2
because it was emulating that so crazy
that like it made an entirely different
game just for that last night now that's
a commitment to detail actually added
two phases like that I gotta say this
might be one of the best uh Five Nights
at Freddy's fan games in term of like
novel creation uh different play style
it was really really really well done
raminov and Derek you guys did a
fantastic job all these people that
worked on it really truly
quite amazing
oh schnoz I didn't click on the schnoz
oh well really like I'm not joking this
was fantastic every part of it was
really really well done like super super
super
well done
so thank you everybody for watching
thank you for being a part of this and
uh here comes the special surprise at
the end
[Music]
and there's the surprise at the end
it's a jump scare great good glad that
happened well ooh extras
here's the oh God look at that thing oh
look at those teeth yeah look at those
ears it's too fleshy I hate it but I
love it that's phenomenal oh my God why
do they look like a creepy Grandpa all
of them every one of them does
no okay this iteration of Freddy is much
taller and lankier than most he's
rocking this his iconic Top Hat in Bow
Tie but both are outfitted with plaid
material similar to Freddy this
iteration of Bonnie is much lankier than
most other designs I don't know if you
know the definition of lanky he's been
giving up
mindless glasses and this color has
shifted from dark Indigo to a tealish
shade of blue
yes this iteration of chica's theme not
around food but sleeping she Dons an eye
count in a sleeping cap and a cupcake
has a pinky how adorable no foxy this
fire pirate themed iteration of Foxy is
withered to maintain that iconic look
that everyone loves we wanted to push
that theme a little further with the
inclusion of lots of piercings
radical
hate everything about it this iteration
of balloon boy isn't a boy at all he's
actually a baby hence the name is oh
balloon baby his face was made more doll
like to match the Eerie Vibe but the
rest of the character cast as always
he's holding his balloons and wearing
his iconic propeller hat
with her lengthy spindly body this
iteration of marionette slash puppet is
more ragdoll-like she's also been given
a nose and a set of ears to add to that
creepy doll look that made it so iconic
in Five Nights at Freddy's 2.
oh during the Final Act of Jr's Freddy
was torn to shreds leaving him with only
one eye and a massive scar great oh
withered body shares almost identical
features to his design in Five Nights at
Freddy's 2.
during the final act because John was
torn apart and ripped open much other
good design probably got the most damage
out of the entire animatronic cast I
don't know about that
maybe ah foxy tweaks quite a beating his
left ear is completely torn off however
he is already pretty withered to begin
with
ah no thank you
ah no thank you no thank you oh oh
you know weirdly enough this is the
least horrifying of all of them somehow
this is the least dramatic
ah she appears to have very strong
connection to Paul Bearer so you can do
a race him during the game's Final Act
thankfully you make it out alive and
manage to Free pallbear by stabbing the
ghost in the back of the neck trapping
goes inside the Barons for the rest of
her days Paul Bearer is a Polaris
lovable and jolly friend that I don't
trust Hong Kong definitely not he Indigo
seem to have another worldly connection
that is caused a divide in reality
perhaps due to their similar deaths the
real question is what is under that
costume I forgot it was a costume
completely weird
okay
[Music]
not so bad
not so bad
okay oh yeah
hey okay
this is terrible nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope it's bad when you know
it's bad from right here
and it just gets worse somehow it just
gets worse nope nope nope none of that
nope nope
nope nope
nope nope nope nope this one's fine I'm
actually okay with this one I'm okay uh
well not take that back I take it back
everything I said
not as okay as I thought I was
that's cute that is cute that's not as
cute
oh that's cute that's pretty cute
that's pretty cute
that's fine that's fine fine with that
fine with that fine all good here fine
so far not fine
that's the line ah fine back to Fine
Again fine fine nah it's all right fine
that's okay fine not that bad scrap
content
oh scrap menu scrap office wow scrap
this all looks great why scrapped why
scrap this looks great
well I did like the final iteration
though so I gotta say that was good
whatever they landed whoa
sting whole bunch of different stuff
that could have happened I mean that's
the thing about this like you could take
all that you made here and make a
completely different game and I would be
totally fine with it because I love the
mechanics that you had they were
actually were fun the hide and seek
thing it wasn't so much just like trying
to find something it was trying to
deduce something from the clues that you
saw that is a good Twist on it I do
enjoy that
it was very fun like pure and simple
very fun
secrets that we hide oh such a funny a
challenging experience but no matter
what the community oh thank you oh thank
you
this was very very well done like you
got to be proud of this this is super
good and it's just one of those things
where I'm saying like take these skills
and make a real game out of it uh not
not that this isn't a real game but I
mean it's something that you can build
in your own Universe because this is all
fantastic like this is just really well
done I just something about the style of
like making these this way is horrifying
I I don't like it it's unsettling in a
way that's it's unsettling in a way that
I haven't typically seen from
animatronics because it's not quite
uncanny valley like the animatronics are
it's just something else entirely that's
just unsettling
I really I hate this but also I love
this fan art that's really good but just
like a glow the curves something about
like the weird like smile
very odd very odd extra renders good
great oh good great good great I I want
to know like who did this it was
probably the same people but honestly
like love that style
party hard you know it you know it God
you know it ugh
fantastic fantastic fantastic Link in
the description go check it out for
yourself support the developers extra
shifts what's in here I don't want to
I don't wanna
oh I don't wanna tierra's DLC
oh no
what is this
seniors Sr all right
I know I don't wanna I'm good turns out
there's a lot of content in here so I'm
just gonna oh
night nothing so I'm just gonna let this
go until the jump scare happens uh but
you know honestly thank you everybody
for watching you know oh I saw that okay
so clearly something here but uh yeah
just thank you all so much for uh being
here and enjoying it I hope you did hope
you enjoyed it and whoa
night too guaranteed wow what is this
doing
huh so thank you everybody so much for
watching uh remember I have a lovely
podcast with Bob Wade that I think
you'll enjoy I've played a bunch of Five
Nights at Freddy's game they're in the
description
um uh
uh can I help you
so take care and uh as always we're
gonna wait until this jumpscare and then
the video is going to end abruptly but
only when that thing scares us
oh
never mind
[Music]